Ray Stevenson had a varied acting career
but arguably His Highest profile roles
were linked to Marvel he made a strong
impression not only on fans but also on
the people he worked with on those films
they spoke up to memorialize him on May
22 2023 news of Stevenson's death at the
age of 58 came as a shock to fans all
over the world his death reportedly
occurred a day earlier and as of the
making of this video the cause has yet
to be made public Stevenson turned in
numerous memorable performances on
screen's big and small throughout his
acting career entertaining moviegoers
and television viewers alike in a wide
range of genres but Marvel fans of
course best remember his work under the
Marvel Banner within the MCU and outside
of it Stevenson's first Marvel role came
in 2008 as the title character in
Punisher war zone a gory and Grim take
on Frank Castle's story that's all too
often overlooked during discussions of
Punisher adaptations sadly this turned
out to be Stevenson's only live-action
turn in the role but he'd get another
crack at a Marvel character a few years
later in 2011's Thor he took on the role
of Warriors 3-member volstag which he
reprized in the 2013 sequel Thor the
Dark World and 2017's Thor Ragnarok my
friends
this is good as word of Stevenson's
death has spread folks that have worked
in front of and behind the camera for
Marvel Productions made touching
statements on social media in his memory
James Gunn director of the Guardians of
the Galaxy Trilogy and holiday special
and now the co-head of DC Studios wrote
so sorry to hear about the passing far
too young of Ray Stevenson I only knew
him a little from shooting post-credits
of Thor 2 in a couple interactions at
events but we had some good laughs and
he was a joy to work with his friends
and family are in my heart today Rosario
Dawson who played Claire temple on the
Netflix Marvel series Daredevil and Luke
Cage also posted a Twitter tribute to
Stevenson calling him vivacious and
unbelievably present and vibrant Dawson
and Stevenson worked extensively on the
upcoming Disney plus Star Wars series
Ahsoka which will arrive on the
streaming service in August 2023.
Stevenson's work as the Fallen Jedi
balance skull on the program is one of
his final performances Stevenson was
remembered well by his fellow Warriors 3
actors on Instagram Tata Nobu asano who
played Hogan reminisced about their time
working together asano describes
Stevenson's kindness helpfulness and
warmth and thanked him for all he did
for him Josh Dallas who played fandral
in the first Thor movie before Zachary
Levi took over the role in Thor the Dark
World and Thor Ragnarok posted about
Stevenson on his Instagram story writing
Rest in Peace Rey Jamie Alexander who
has played lady Sif in a number of
Marvel Productions shared some photos of
herself in Stevenson on set she began
her caption Rey man my heart is
shattered you made every day so much fun
on and Offset you always looked after me
always made me laugh Alexander recalled
Stevenson visiting her in the hospital
in their Unforgettable dinners though
she had plenty of stories to share about
him she wished they had the chance to
make even more memories she concluded
her post I'm sending so much love to
your beautiful family love you just as
he did with fans of his work Ray
Stevenson clearly left a lasting
impression on many of his co-stars he is
already sorely missed